HOLLYWOOD.
>> Brian: BIG NEWS IS BUFFALO
HAS SNOWOVER NIGHT PRESIDENT
BIDEN RETURNING FROM THE G-20
SUMMIT TAKING ONLY ONE QUESTION
AS HE IS PRESSED ON THAT FATAL
MISSILE STRIKE IN POLAND AND
WHERE IT CAME FROM.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYING THAT
THE MISSILES HAVE LANDED IN
POLAND WERE NOT UKRAINIAN?
>> THAT'S NOT THE EVIDENCE.
>> Steve: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND U.S. MARINE VET JOEY JONES
JOINS US LIVE FROM THE PATRIOT
AWARDS HERE IN HOLLYWOOD.
GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
>> SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
IT LOOKS LIKE WE WERE ON THE
VERGE A COUPLE DAYS AGO OF WORLD
WAR III IF THAT MISSILE WAS FROM
RUSSIA, BUT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
THE UKRAINIANS, ACCORDING TO OUR
PENTAGON, SHOT IT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING
TO ME OF THE THREE ACTORS SAYING
SOMETHING, POLAND, THE U.S. AND
UKRAINE ALL SAYING WHAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO SAY.
ALL SAYING WHAT IS MOST
ADVANTAGEOUS FOR THEM.
UKRAINE SAYS THIS IS A RUSSIAN
MISSILE.
BRING THOSE NATO FORCES IN AND
GO TO WAR.
OF COURSE THE U.S. SAYS NO, THAT
WAS NOT A RUSSIAN MISSILE AND WE
SHOULDN'T JUST BRING THOSE NATO
FORCES IN AND GO TO WAR.
WHAT DO WE DO AS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SEE THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT OF
SKEPTICISM.
NOT OVER THE LEGITIMACY OF
UKRAINE FIGHTING BACK BUT THE
INFORMATION WE ARE GETTING FROM
OUR GOVERNMENT ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND THERE IS NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT IT'S TRUE.
IT'S VERY SKEPTICAL.
>> Brian: RUSSIANS SHOULD BE
SCRAMBLING TO KEEP A LID ON IT.
INSTEAD DON'T RETURN GENERAL
MILLEY'S CALL.
WE TALKED TO THEM ABOUT
DEESCALATING THEY DON'T CARE.
>> THEY DON'T CARE OR -- YEAH,
IT'S NOT THAT THEY JUST DON'T
CARE THIS IS A DIFFICULT WAR TO
BE FOUGHT.
THE NEXT STEP IS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
NOBODY WANTS THAT.
I DON'T THINK THE RUSSIANS WANT
THAT SO THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO WIN,
OPPORTUNITIES TO ANTAGONIZE.
PERHAPS OPPORTUNITIES TO JUST
GET US TO THE TABLE.
THIS HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO
WATCH.
FOR ME, I CAN'T GIVE YOU HIGHER
STRATEGY, NATIONAL SECURITY FROM
A 30,000-FOOT VIEW, I I CAN TELL
YOU I HAVE GOT BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THAT WENT TO SCHOOL TO
TAKE BOMBS APART.
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE WAYS THE
ORDNANCE IS MOVING AROUND AND
THE WAY SOME OF THE ORDNANCE HAS
BEEN LOST.
OUR LACK OF ABILITY TO TRACK
WHAT WE SENT THERE AND WHERE
IT'S GONE HAS HAD REAL WORLD
CONSEQUENCE FORCE OUR OWN
MILITARY AND INTELLIGENCE AND
CIVILIANS THAT GO AROUND THE
WORLD AND FIND ORDNANCE LOST ON
THE BATTLEFIELD AND PUT ON THE
BLACK MARKET THAT'S ONLY GOING
TO GO UP THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY
ONLY GO UP BECAUSE OF THIS.
>> THOSE HEROES YOU TALK ABOUT
TAKING APART BOMBS ON THE FRONT
LINES OR FIRST RESPONDERS GOING
TO BE IN THIS ROOM TONIGHT FOR
THE PATRIOT AWARDS.
YOU ARE PRESENTING THE COURAGE
AWARD WITH HARRIS FAULKNER, TELL
US ABOUT IT.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE AWARD
TRULY DOES EXEMPLIFY COURAGE.
WHAT IT MEANS IS SOMEBODY WHO
DID SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO DO.
AND PUT THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE.
RISK THEIR LIFE.
LOST THEIR LIFE.
TO DO THEIR JOB.
IN A JOB THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE.
CAN'T TELL HOW IS WINNING IT.
WE HAVE GOT TO WAIT FOR TONIGHT
FOR THAT I WAS ABLE TO BE IN ON
THE SECRET AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHAT, I'M NERVOUS AND HUMBLED
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY, THAT'S HOW
MUCH THIS MEANS FOR ME AND HOW
IMPORTANT.
>> Brian: HARRIS FAULKNER WILL
BE OTHE STAGE.
>> HARRIS WILL BE THE STAR.
I WILL BE BACKUP.
IMPACTFUL.
SOMETHING EVERY VIEWER THAT CAN
TUNE IN DOES.
AT LEAST FOR THAT LAST HALF HOUR
OF THE SHOW THIS AWARD IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
>> SIX CATEGORIES AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE BIG ONES.
>> WATCH THE PATRIOT AWARDS
STREAMING LIVE ON FACE TONIGHT
JOEY THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU GETTING UP WITH
US.
>> OKAY, CAN YOU HIT THE SLOTS
AGAIN NOW.
>> I'M HITTING THE GYM.
AWAY FROM THE BAR AND GAMBLING
I'M GOING TO THE GYM.
>> Steve: I WENT TO THE GYM
YESTERDAY.
THE VIEW IS OUT AT THE TOOL
POOLS WHERE JANICE IS.
>> I WILL TAKE THAT SHALLOW
WATER AT THE POOL ISN'T JUST FOR
KIDS KIDS WHO HAVE
ELECTRONNENINGS, CAN I KIND OF
WALK IN IT.
>> Ainsley: I LOVE THAT SHALLO